so you decide to say yes to Evan uh even
though you know I guess you understood
there could be some profound
ramifications and Trump was very much uh
in control or about to be in control of
the party at that time
um what were your experiences like on
the trail uh were you concerned about
frankly threats to your physical safety
um what what was campaigning with Evan
like yeah so many ways first of all I
would say it was overall a just a
incredible experience and really
transformative in in my life so I would
do it 10 times over even though it was
only for a couple of months
um I like to say I got in many ways the
best ways of running for you know on a
presidential ticket in that it was
short-lived one didn't have to do it for
two years four years we didn't have to
spend that much time raising money
because we just didn't raise much money
and it was too late and we didn't have
you know years of Oppo flying at us we
did have some Oppo and and I'll get to
the safety point in a minute and I got
to run like really run with a partner
like we both were first-time candidates
um kind of having to figure it out as as
we went and and then I think the thing
that was kind of the
um theme around our our campaign was
just that we were wanting we were giving
voters an affirmative and a positive
pro-democracy option at a time when
voters were very dissatisfied with the
two options they saw both these
candidates as corrupt it was very much
as it has tended to be
um there was a hold your nose effect
where you would hear a lot from voters
that they were having to go to the
thinking about going to the polls and
having to hold their nose for one of
those candidates Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump whereas our supporters
would come and say thank you like thank
you so much for giving me an affirmative
option that we can go to the polls and
vote for and be really proud walk out
with our head held high that we voted
for for you with your positive message
with your bridge building message with
your pro-democracy message you know your
anti-corrupt and Corruption message and
Beyond
um and so I just found it incredibly
inspiring especially when students would
say you know this is my first time
casting a vote and I kind of didn't
imagine this you know the way the
presidential cycle had shaped up I
couldn't have imagined that and now I
get to vote for you or you know veterans
who had said something similar just
um in the states we campaigned in which
were limited but just Utah is where we
ended up spending the most time at the
end you just saw like real uh retail
kind of local politics was it's just a
ton of self-organizing people organizing
their own events for us you know setting
them up at their town hall to make sure
they had an opportunity to hear from
that from us and
um it really felt like the best of
America on the other hand we did
especially once we started to catch you
know at least a bit of fire in Utah and
appear to be a threat there
um the Trump campaign in particular sent
um hecklers and detractors to our events
who would cause a lot of problems
um and be yelling and screaming there
were threats to our safety there were
cryptic letters that were sent to my
home while I was traveling you know
where my husband young children were at
the time that you know we had to you
know turn into the FBI we ended up
having to get security at the end uh we
couldn't qualify we didn't qualify for
Secret Service it was kind of too late
anyway so we had to hire our own private
security
um so it was
um you know sometimes when I reflect
back there was moving so quickly that I
couldn't even fully appreciate at the
moment
um the type of risk that we may have
been facing but it certainly was
certainly there and it certainly reminds
me now of the types of risks obviously
all people in public life face but a lot
of the election
officials who who had to stand up
particularly against their own party for
the legitimacy of the the 20 2011
results it's gotten darker since even
that cycle
um though thank you for your service and
your courage uh and uh congratulations
on giving people something positive to
vote for so again you did get I want to
say about 20 of the vote in Utah which
is a freaking ton I mean if you think
about it yeah so in Utah we got it was
like a little over 21 I mean at one
point yeah at one point we were actually
pulling ahead or even with the other
candidates Trump actually he didn't come
to Utah but he sent a pence there and
Pence's big message it was very clear
and it was really powerful it was really
about two things one was the Supreme
Court and kind of like you need to vote
for Republican to get our judges on the
Supreme Court and also just come home
like come home to the Republican party
you know this is home to you which is
really pretty interesting you know we
think about politics as it really serves
this role in people's lives of this
place where they belong is their
identity and Pence stepped into that for
the campaign he told people come home
and and that really was effective you
know for those Republicans um but we
still yeah we got over 21 of the vote in
in Idaho we got 12
um I I believe
um you know we weren't not all these
ballots were counted everywhere because
they don't count them unless they're
going to make a difference on the
outcome but we got the highest number of
presidential write-in votes sort of in
any cycle ever you know up to that point
um so I'm very I'm very very
um proud of what we were able to do
um on a shoestring budget you know the
dollar per vote couldn't be beat um in
terms of the amount spent versus
um you know what we did and more
importantly it was the message we were
able to get across and and form the
foundation for a new movement in
politics which continues today and
um you know you've really taken the
mantle and are running with it's awesome
that you frankly managed to like get
their attention to the point where they
had to divert uh Pence to head to Utah
because the last thing anyone thought
was going to happen is they had to spend
time in Utah
you guys did great yeah it was really
funny actually Trump started to talk
about our campaign not even at his
rallies as we know he's a little bit
sensitive you might say and so he didn't
like the fact that there was any kind of
challenge
um and so he's like there's this guy by
McMullen who's you know campaigning
going coffee shop to coffee shop in Utah
which is like pretty funny because
notoriously you know Utah is a heavily
they don't really drink so much missing
him don't drink much coffee yeah so it
shows how much he knew about it
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you